[Music]
i
i've always been you know such a fan of
you know dancing with the stars felt
great oh i'm gonna bring it baby
hard to believe dancing with the stars
is entering its 25th season the show
premiered in june 2005 and here we are
12 years later still salsa ing along
with our favorite stars and pros to get
you pumped for next month's season
premiere here are nine stars you
probably forgot competed on the show we
feel great about it all the competitors
and all the celebrities on the show and
the dancers everybody's amazing and it's
just incredible before nick carter was
named runner-up in 2015 his younger
brother aaron was a contestant in 2009
and he placed fifth not bad
i'm gonna do the best i can you know and
that's that's all i can do the carters
aren't the only famous siblings who've
danced how you taking this comment about
your sister when they said you just out
danced come on no it's great i expected
it i mean she's not that great of a
dancer poor kim kardashian was
eliminated third when she competed in
2008
there's so many amazing people and it's
just kind of up to the fan base and the
charisma as for rob he fared much better
he was the runner-up on season 13 in
2011. the end of the day i'm focusing on
me and cheryl and just our dance and one
step at a time
[Music]
in 2010 audrina patridge left the hills
for the ballroom i'm going to take
everything in and use it to my advantage
just one year later kristin cavallari
hit the floor audrina gave her some
advice
she said it's a lot of fun so just enjoy
it the show has seen stars from all
walks of life
pro boxer floyd mayweather rapper lil
kim and miley cyrus's dad singer billy
ray all gave it their best shot
former beverly hills 90210 alum shannon
doherty went for the mirror ball in
2010. that's going to be really exciting
it's definitely going to be exciting i'm
coming after you
sadly she got the boot in the first
round
shannon told et at the time the special
reason why she signed up for the show my
dad had
a stroke and
it gives him inspiration to
you know
walk five steps down a
hospital hall
then then i was more than willing to
go through the nerves of a live audience
and everything else for him get ready to
samba roomba cha-cha and all that good
stuff when dancing with the stars
returns to abc on september 18th
[Music]